je trouve que la justice est un petit
peu trop faible parce que quand il ya
des mineurs qui commettent des crimes à
des coups de couteau aux copains qu'à 14
ans j'imagine que c'est très très grave
alors bien sûr qu'il faut lui donner une
leçon il n'a pas l'expérience de la vie
mais il a déjà le jugement donc mis à
part les adolescents et les mineurs tous
ces terroristes ne sont pas condamnés
comme il se doit ce qu'il faudrait faire
je ne sais pas mais je pense que on
devrait appliquer les lois qui existent
quand on aura fait ça on aura à peu près
résolu le problème
on entend parler sans arrêt de
renouvellement de loi etc
on s'aperçoit qu'en réalité ces lois
existent déjà
simplement c'est compliqué d appliquer
ces longs de les appliquer c'est
difficile voilà donc
il ya une espèce comme ça de laxisme et
à mon avis fini et les remises de peine
ça c'est sûr mais toi les peines
incompressibles sambre saisi ça dépend
ça dépend il faut respecter un peu la
justice ici mais je pense qu'elle n'est
pas assez sévère dans certains cas
activement bas par exemple il est
inadmissible
il est inadmissible que l'on ce que l'on
voit en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne la taxe sur sur les forces de
police il ya un respect un certain
respect de l'ordre et puis met le feu
dans les eaux voitures des gens des
missions qui sont de condition modeste
commune c'est inadmissible non plus ça
ne change rien à leur cause voilà même
s'ils ont des problèmes il des choses a
revendiqué ce n'est pas en agissant
comme ils agissent qui vont obtenir
quelque chose il faut qu'on ait un débat
là-dessus effectivement il ya de ski
il ya des éléments qui pose souci je
sais pas si je suis pour les peines
incompressibles systématiquement chaque
cas et a été étudié quoi c'est s'armer
après c'est comme vous dites c'est un
vaste débat et je me sens pas moi-même
la de vous répondre oui je suis pour nom
suis contre en tous les cas c'est un
débat qu'il faut lancer
oui un peu un souci à ce niveau là et je
pense qu'il faudrait vraiment avoir une
peut-être une tolérance zéro ou en tout
cas des peines puissent allemands
s'impliquent nous permet vraiment de
faire comprendre à la délinquance
il ya des choses qui sont intolérables
il ya des choses qui font vraiment mal à
notre république et qu'on ne peut pas
tolérer sur le tournesol ne pense pas
qu'il faut qu'ils aient répression
judiciaire au niveau des parents mais je
pense que c'est à cet âge là ils jouent
un rôle assez important et je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être un meilleur
encadrement peut-être un meilleur suivi
peut être un indice positif qui
permettre d'assurer une meilleure
pérennité dans rapports parents enfants
notamment dans certaines des zones qui
sont un problème il ya tellement
d'affaires que la justice ne prend pas
le temps de répondre à la demande des
tribunaux sont débordés ont monsieur
moretti essaye de changer la donne mais
si beaucoup de travail
bon c'est sûr qu'ils qu il connaît les
cas puisqu'il a été avocat dont il
connaît les deux les des dessous de la
faire d'un côté ou de l'autre
mais bon c'est ça prendra du temps pour
tout changer il faudrait une refonte du
code pénal ont trop trop et c'est à dire
que je pense que avec toute l'actualité
qu'on a actuellement basse et s'est
passé c'est l'air d'un premier but d'un
premier point de vue mais oui je pense
qu'il faut une refonte du code pénal
ouais les les juges font un travail
difficile mais appliquent la loi donc
sir pas de modification de la loi ben il
y aura il y aura de plus en plus de
délinquance dans l'avenir je pense